su médico le colocará una inyección
epidural de esteroides para reducir la
inflamación de su columna reduciendo así
el dolor y dando tiempo para que su
condición sane la columna está
conformada por vértebras óseas apiladas
una sobre otra discos intervertebrales
amortiguadores que se encuentran entre
las vértebras ligamentos y músculos que
conectan los huesos y la médula espinal
con sus nervios espinales ramificados la
médula espinal está cubierta del líquido
cefalorraquídeo y rodeada de una
membrana protectora llamada duramadre
justo afuera de esta membrana se
encuentra el espacio epidural cada disco
intervertebral está compuesto de una
capa exterior resistente llamada anillo
fibroso y de un material interno
esponjoso llamado núcleo pulposo debido
a la edad o lesiones
el anillo fibroso se puede debilitar o
degenerar como resultado el disco puede
hincharse dentro de las estructuras
vasculares y neurales causando
inflamación y dolor
si el anillo se daña por completo el
núcleo puede filtrarse causando una
hernia discal la inflamación e hinchazón
resultante puede irritar algunos de los
nervios espinales cercanos provocando
una condición conocida como
radiculopatía las hernias discales en la
región baja o lumbar de la espalda
tienden a producir un dolor lacerante
que se extiende a la pierna una
condición llamada ciática si se produce
una hernia en algún disco del cuello el
dolor se irradia hacia el brazo otra
condición que puede ocasionar dolor e
inflamación en el área de los nervios
espinales es la osteoartritis que puede
provocar un crecimiento excesivo de los
huesos en las articulaciones de la
columna lo que da como resultado la
compresión de los nervios espinales
cercanos la inyección epidural de
esteroides es un procedimiento
mínimamente invasivo para comenzar su
médico adormecer a la piel de su espalda
con una anestesia local utilizando una
radiografía como guía su médico
insertará una aguja entre los huesos y a
través de los ligamentos de su columna
hasta
el espacio epidural al nivel de la
inflamación una vez que la aguja se ha
insertado en el espacio epidural su
médico inyectar a la solución de
esteroides
después del procedimiento puede aplicar
hielo al área de la inyección para
aliviar el dolor y tomar analgésicos de
venta libre puede volver a manejar
después de 24 horas